so I'm not even going to go through them
I just want a yay or a nay questions A
through C in question one yay
yeah right okay fantastic we'll come
back to those questions shortly I'll
tell you why later on 2a and 2b let's
have a look at these so one thing I
really like is that you can see all of
the working is here so you can know
exactly why if they give to its negative
side own task for working by the way so
if you didn't pour I think it's no big
deal you can see that we're thinking of
that pair of numbers 2 X 3 X and that
let's just divide up I will point out
four questions where it's see this
number at the front you know how there's
a number hiding in front of the x
squared what's the number it's a 1 so
you might recall that we call these all
three of these we call them monic
quadratic equations because mono for one
like monorail okay so when it's Manik
and you think of that pair of numbers
two or three I'm very happy for you to
immediately go to this line right you've
thought of the 2 and the 3 what you can
do with that is make them part of the
factors that you come up with X plus 3 X
plus 2 and that's why x equals negative
3 and negative 2 those are your
solutions ok please remember Brian
remember what solutions are solutions
and numbers you can put into X up here
and they work right if you put in
negative 2 it everywhere you see X then
sure enough that stuff on the Left does
B does equal 0
right if you put in negative 3 are
people let's just quickly do it negative
3 squared is 9 5 times negative 3 is
minus 15 9 minus 15 plus 6 sure enough
it equals 0 ok so that's what x equals
negative 2 negative 3 that's the
significance of those values when you
have a look here I wouldn't like it if
you put like a comma there so that we we
see these together negative 3 & 4 there
good to me now did anyone get
party-party okay right part see the
reason why only one of you got it is
because despite looking so much like
these other questions it's actually in a
very important way qualitatively
different if you looked at it and you
scratched your head that's okay we
search for a pair of numbers right
what rules or what conditions did your
pair of numbers have to fit like two and
three why did you pick those they they
add up to five and they multiply to 6
now when you look down here you try and
use the same strategy you're like add up
to 3 multiply to 1 I mean the only
numbers I've also got know that multi
don't want to like what 1 and 1 okay and
they don't add up to 3 so you suddenly
find yourself in this dilemma yeah just
put your pen down for a second for me as
a teacher it's always really important
I'm like why are we learning this
whatever is the next thing that we're
learning okay you have to have a why
okay in maths so often and we've seen
this many many times before so after we
develop new ideas because our old ideas
which served us really well in
particular problems are as useful when
you just change the problem a teeny bit
you're like oh no what do I do with this
now right they look very similar they're
similar in almost every way but changing
a tiny detail in this case it's these
numbers here renders your previous
techniques like Pythagoras renders them
useless right you've could you've got to
develop new stuff that's why we invent
stuff like trigonometry so I'm going to
teach you a technique today that's all
about trying to wrap your head around a
problem
like this and it's actually a really
beautiful technique I want you to make a
heading for me and I need to keep this
stuff on the board so part of me if it's
a little bit trip they're handy I'd like
you to make underneath review questions
is completing the square now I promise
this heading will make sense in a minute
as soon as we start to have a go at
these questions over
here I'm gonna hijack those questions at
the beginning and I'm gonna say if I
asked you I'm just gonna write for
example if I asked you to solve x
squared plus 6x plus 9 equals 0 if I
asked you to solve them then because we
know how it factorizes this is actually
a very easy problem so you guys could do
this in your sleep I'm gonna reverse
what you did you expanded so I've
factorized that equals 0 and now what
I'm searching for is values of X to make
that work there's only one what is it x
equals I think I heard it negative 3
will do the job for us right you put it
in there negative 3 plus 3 that gives
you 0 it works everything looks good ok
now we like these guys these guys are
really nice they're perfect squares
they're perfect squares and so in fact
if what I had done was asked you to
factorize these hopefully you might
start to recognize oh look see these
guys on the ends see 949 25 they're all
squares right see the numbers in the
middle six negative 14 10 those guys are
related to the squares how are they well
what's 1/2 of 6 which is the square root
what's 1/2 of negative 14 negative which
is you can square it to get 49 and half
of 10 of course is 5 which is this
square root over here okay so what I can
do is imagine have a look at this guy
here if I said I'm actually going to
change it a little bit if I have this
this is my second example okay x squared
I really should have put this one
instead x squared plus 4 X plus 1 if you
tried to solve this question you will
end up in exactly the same problem as
you had with this one you can't think of
a number that pair of numbers that adds
to 4 and multiplies to 1 so here's what
I'm going to do let's just put this guy
here leave that to one side and see this
plus one
put him over on the right-hand side for
reasons that we come clear in a moment I
just want to focus on the left okay now
can you see it's like got a piece
missing it's got a piece missing right
what I want to do is turn the left-hand
side into a square I want to add
something to it that turns the left-hand
side into a square just like all these
guys are squares you see that okay so
what square would it have come from
right for example you guys can see this
came from X plus 3 squared
you guys wrote this answer this came
from X minus 7 squared and that's how
you got this answer okay so being that
I've got this number and I'm trying to
find this number how do I go from this
number to that and from this number to
that and from this number
to that I have to do two things and I
mentioned to you before first I've got
to have it that gives you five and then
I've got to square it that gives you the
25 okay
now have a look at in this instance you
can take this guy right to get from here
to here and I'd love you to write this
down with me maybe another color if
you've got it I'm gonna do two things
I'm going to have the number and then
I'm after that you're gonna square it
half then square you guys can do this
for me
carving is not too hard half of 4 is 2
and then you square it which gives you 4
ok so I'm gonna do that I'm gonna add 4
ok now if you added 4 sorry I should
have put that back in that other color
if you added 4 to one side well this is
an equation right you can't just go
adding things to one side because you
feel like it because it makes things
nice and neat yeah add four to one side
you've got to add 4 to the other side so
I'll do that ok
now for the step I'm about to noon X or
the steps I'm gonna do next I actually
just want you to watch this bit so
having gotten this down put your pins
down and watch what's about to happen I
promise I won't rub this off until we're
ready okay the reason we added four is
because now this thing here is a square
just like of these things were like your
picture of square and it looks like that
doesn't it okay but what I'm trying to
say to you is that these are algebraic
versions of squares so what Square is it
well it's something squared I'm trying
to reverse engineer this right I'm
trying to go from here back to the
question I don't know if any of you
watch the work the show Jeopardy before
it's at us game show and they give you
answers you have to come up with
questions right where this has come from
is X plus 2 you could go ahead and you
could prove it for yourself just like we
did in question 1 by expanding this you
will get this here so that's the left
hand side what's the right hand side
what's negative 1 plus 4 now hmm when we
had 0 on the right hand side up here at
this point we were done we were finished
ok but we don't have 0 on the right hand
side here the answer is not negative 2 I
need a teeny little bit more work ok you
can pick up your pen again now go ahead
and write this X plus 2 or squared
equals 3 ok
now where do I go from here well there's
squares I kind of need to get rid of
squares what's the opposite of squaring
we take the square root so if you take
the square root on the left hand side
the square is gone if you take the
square root of the right hand side you
get the square root of 3 but just be
careful just be careful
this is not the only number you can
square that gives you 3 there's another
number the negative so I have to write a
plus or minus in there that's really
really important ok one more line and
then we finally have our answer I just
want X I don't want X plus 2 so what do
I do to both sides to get X on its own
subtract two I'm gonna write it at the
front now what does this mean what does
that mean
right